une place aux matchs des idées
confrontation point de vue ce soir entre
françois kalfon et nicolas tenzer on va
s'arrêter sur les alliances à gauche en
vue des élections régionales le cas des
hôtes france est en train de faire des
émules mais aussi de poser un sacré
casse-tête dans certaines régions
l'union de toutes les gauches dans le
nord pourrait-elle se reproduire en île
de france par exemple eh ben c'est loin
d'être sûr ça supposerait que certains
ou certaines s'efface c'est pas gagné on
va en parler avec nos invités juste
après les détails de samia de chair elle
incarne désormais la possibilité d'une
union celles des verts des socialistes
des insoumis et des communistes aux
élections régionales dans les hauts de
france les quatre formations se lancent
ensemble dès le premier tour derrière
l'écologiste karima delli
nous ne laisserons pas l'histoire se
répéter de 2015 étions aux portes du
conseil régional désormais nous sommes
unis pour gagner une alliance que
d'autres rêverait de reproduire ailleurs
mais le scénario nordistes ne semblent
pas si facile à exporter en
ile-de-france trois listes de gauche se
font concurrence
clémentine autain porte les couleurs des
insoumis et des communistes
audrey pulvar présentait socialiste et
julien bayou soutenu par benoît hamon
mène la liste écologiste sawey pardon de
le dire de la gueule
qu'on se rassemble effectivement et que
ce rassemblement s'opère avant avant le
premier tour aujourd'hui il me semble
que julien bayou par les gestes qu'il
pose et le projet qu'il porte et le
meilleur visage pour l'île de france par
tous les écologistes à peine à s'unir
derrière leur propre candidat après
leurs succès électoraux aux dernières
municipales
les verts s'estime en position de force
les négociations tournent au bras de fer
jusqu'à l'échec en auvergne rhône-alpes
ou l'écologiste fabienne grébert et la
socialiste najat vallaud belkacem
mèneront des deux listes différentes
les écologistes en gagner grenoble on a
gagné lyon la métropole de lyon annecy
donc je comprends qu'ils aient une
nostalgie au parti socialiste mais que
najat vallaud belkacem qui était élu
auprès de colomb et après ministre de
manuel valls puisse dire tiens venait
derrière moi ça va sembler incongrue un
peu hâtivement sur treize régions la
gauche n'a réussi à se rassembler que
dans les hauts de france
si les régionales sont le galop d'essai
de la prochaine présidentielle
la perspective d'une union semble bien
incertaine avec nous pour le match des
idées ce soir françois kalfon bienvenue
vous êtes conseiller régional d'île de
france membre du bureau national du
parti socialiste nicolas tenzer
bienvenus cette politologue philosophe
essayiste président du centre d'étude et
de réflexion pour l'action politique et
directeur de la revue le banquet merci à
tous les deux françois kalfon je vais
quand même commencer par vous puisque
vous soutenez audrey pulvar en ile de
france
est ce que vous pourriez vous ranger
derrière julien bayou dans ces
régionales est ce qu audrey pulvar
pourrait se retirer en sa faveur
écoute c'est envisageable ou pas je vois
que c'est bientôt le printemps et que d
elle pousse à nos amis donc je suis tout
à fait ravi mais pour redevenir sérieux
cinq minutes au fond qu'attend la gauche
c'est que nous puissions sortir de ce
débat pré construit entre madame le pen
et monsieur macron serre que finalement
la gauche puisse reprendre toute sa
place et qui ne logique de rassemblement
je ne suis pas sûr que la logique de
rassemblement consiste à aller chercher
des poux dans la tête des uns et des
autres comme je n'ai entendu de monsieur
piol cet été audrey pulvar a proposé le
rassemblement à julien bayou sont
d'ailleurs présager qu'ils seraient
devant tout cela a reçu une fin de non
recevoir
je trouve qu'elle est plutôt derrière
dans les sondages ah non je crois pas
non
devant bah écoutez je peux pas vous
révéler devant julien bayou dans les
sondages mais plutôt à julien bayou de
sorel je suis pas dans une course de
petits chevaux si un moment donné pris
par la conscience clémentine autain
julien bayou et audrey pulvar voulaient
se rassembler je ne verrais que des
avantages
maintenant cette idée de l'hégémonie un
peu pile je gagne face tu perds parce
que c'est un peu ce que nous proposent
les verts ça correspond pas à notre
logiciel politique
karima delli est tête de liste pour les
hôtes france de la france a soumise au
parti socialiste où le monde se
rassemble je ne vois pas pourquoi à
chaque fois le prix d'unités seraient à
payer par une force politique et je le
dis avec beaucoup beaucoup de comment
dire de deux visées stratégiques
il ya beaucoup de débats quand même
qu'ils se posent il ya le statut de la
république est ce qu'on est
universaliste
ou est ce qu'on veut au contraire
reconnaître telle et telle minorité est
ce qu'on veut une croissance verte ou
est ce qu'on veut la décroissance
eh bien il ya des débats là dessus nous
nous sommes favorables à une croissance
verte nous ne sommes pas favorables à
des croissances
nous sommes favorables à une république
universelle nous ne sommes pas
favorables au morcellement de la société
voyez ces débats un peu plus sérieux que
de savoir si pierre paul jacques et en
l'occurrence clémentine audrey julien
vont s'entendre autour d'une table si
c'est sur un contenu au profit des
franciliens alors bien sûr on ne
trouvera toujours autour de la table moi
je pense qu'il ya effectivement
plusieurs plusieurs éléments à prendre
en considération
d'abord effectivement je pense que pour
les alliances au niveau régional c'est
quelque chose qui est faisable qui est
envisageable dans le cadre d'une gestion
d'une région bon je pense que on n'est
pas à ce niveau là dans la gestion ou
dans la conception des grandes lignes
stratégiques qui elles vont se poser
plus tard et justement ça c'est le
deuxième point sur le deuxième point là
on s'aperçoit qu'entre les différentes
composantes de la gauche pourrait dire
d'ailleurs une certaine manière à peu
près la même chose de la droite on a des
débats fondamentaux ya ce que lucien
caleçon a évoqué bien sûr qu'ils sont
fondamentaux mais il y en a d'autres
il y en a sur l'europe qu'est ce qu'on
attend de l'europe il y en a sur quel
est notre rapport comment nous allons
nous comporter vis-à-vis d'un certain
nombre de régions
dictatoriaux voire criminel la russie la
syrie ont fait aujourd'hui le dixième
anniversaire de la révolution syrienne
la chine ce sont des sujets essentiels
sur l'éducation quels sont les contenus
qu'on entend privilégier dans
l'éducation de nos enfants je parle pas
du nombre de profs mais je parle
vraiment des choses fondamentales et là
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui qu'entre les
différentes composantes de la gauche il
ya des distinctions majeures
il ya des projets de société qui sont
complètement différents de médiation je
pensais que je pense que c'est quand m
c'est quand même très difficile après il
ya aussi des questions
troisièmement les des questions de
personnes oscillera qui pourra sembler
alors encore une fois dans un cadre
régional c'est envisageable dans un
cadre national je pense que là aussi il
faut pas non plus complètement et les
laissions elle serait possible ou pas
benoît hamon ce matin sur notre antenne
qui nous dit ça aurait de la gueule
qu'on se rassemble et que ce
rassemblement se fasse avant le premier
tour je veux bien me mettre à la
disposition de dre et clémentine pour
discuter dans quelles conditions on le
fait encore il peut y avoir des
médiations pour les régionales ça ne me
choque absolument pas je pense que là
encore une fois si on est on entend que
les régionales soit une sorte de
préfiguration la présidentielle c'est
quand même ça la vraie question
là on en est quand même extrêmement de
loin on en est vraiment très loin parce
que il ya ces différences devant il ya
des projets politiques des projets de
société une vision du monde qui sont
radicalement antinomiques
donc ce n'est pas pour demain et sonore
mais regardez-moi je vais revenir à la
région parce que tout à l'heure j'étais
sur les grands principes et que c'est
une campagne des régionales en région
ile de france il ya 750 milles sur une
région de 12 millions et demi de
personnes demandeurs de logement eh bien
il ya une question fondamentale qui se
pose sur l'articulation entre écologie
et social
est-ce qu'on peut au nom de l'écologie
refusé comme ça arrive souvent et
compris dernièrement à paris dans le
16ème arrondissement où les écologistes
avec la droite se sont opposés un projet
de logement social en 16ème
arrondissement est-ce qu'on peut au nom
de l'écologie refusé cette urgence
sociale qui par voie de conséquence
permet aussi la croissance par la
novation thermique des bâtiments par la
construction qui est un acte écologique
de construire ma ville sur la ville
est-ce qu'on peut refuser cette urgence
sociale qui consiste à loger tous les
gens qui sont malades mêmes priorités
non mais je ne dis pas que c'est pas
c'est que je sais qu'à l'époque par
exemple quelqu'un comme emmanuelle cosse
qui nous a rejoint depuis et écologistes
et suivez les questions de logement et
ailes articulées parfaitement la
construction durable de logements donc
une vision écologique et les objectifs
environnementaux
moi je ne veux pas qu'on sacrifie dur
main et en particulier ceux qui sont
finalement les plus exclues sur l'autel
de l'écologie je donne un deuxième
exemple il ya une ligne 17 du métro qui
va arroser la seine saint denis et le
val d'oise d'un métro eh bien je vois
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
secteurs au sein de l'écologie politique
refuse le métro donc il faut m'expliquer
la cohérence entre d'un côté refusé la
voiture à paris ce que nous refusons
également et de refuser le métro pour la
banlieue on peut pas d'un côté dire les
premiers de corvée il habite en deuxième
couronne et les applaudir au moment du
covin et leur refuser des transports
collectifs ça pose une difficulté est
les autres thèmes que je voudrais
aborder avec vous ce soir c'est
l'officialisation de cette liste de 318
noms de personnalités issues de la
diversité proposée pour baptiser des
russes et la ministre déléguée chargée
de la ville nadia qui avait été chargé
de cette mission par emmanuel macron et
cette liste est loin de faire
l'unanimité alors on va accueillir dans
ce match pour en parler nicolas bancel
bonsoir vous êtes historien professeur à
l'université de lausanne
auteur de ce livre le post colonialisme
et vous faites partie du conseil
scientifique qui a élaboré cette liste
ça ne vous a pas échappé elle fait face
à une avalanche de critiques cette liste
la plus virulente est peut-être celle de
bruno retailleau président du groupe
elle erre ici au sénat les bonnes
intentions qui ont mené à la création
d'une liste de célébrités basée sur
l'origine ne peuvent pas masquer son
caractère racialiste dit il emmanuel
macron jouent le jeu des des coloniaux
qui ne seront jamais rassasié des
repentance de la france
le choix du professeur blanchard est
révélateur comment réagissez vous à cela
la première action ça serait de droit
qui lisent quand même des biographes ont
été posées par le conseil scientifique
parce que il n'y a aucune base raciale
sur les délibérations de cette crise
3000 noms étaient ont été étudiés on
applique ce voter pour la liste des 300
millions seraient encore beaucoup de
noms qui sont possibles et un travail
qui doit se poursuivre et je rappelle
que toutes les origines étrangères sont
mentionnés dans ce travail vous avez
effectivement des ressortissants de l'ue
première lexus trois maires français
l'ex empire colonial vous avez des
ressortissants qui proviennent d'asie
vous en avez qui arrivent d'europe des
états unis
donc c'est plus c'est une liste monde on
peut pas vraiment pas accuser le je
pense le conseil scientifique d'avoir
agi sous l'emprise d'une conception
racialiste raki la licra qui se posent
des questions sur votre liste là aussi
je la cite dans le recueil des noms des
quartiers d immigration et d diversité
territoriale proposée par monsieur
blanchard figure le citoyen français
andré isaac dit pierre dac
ancien militant de la licra nous
aimerions savoir au titre de quelle
diversité il figure sur cette liste
vous avez une réponse alors ça c'est une
question posé une colle parce que je
n'ai pas étudié
personnellement moi la biographie de
données sud d'alger suite contre il aura
une origine étrangère été naturalisés ou
posez une colle là je ne ne pas répondre
7 d'accord la micra n'aura pas sa
réponse c'est pas grave pas assez de
femmes dit on au ministère d'elisabeth
moreno et est-ce là vous avez une
réponse ou pas oui j'ai une réponse
les deux types de réponses la première
chose c'est que c'est vrai il n'ya pas
assez de femmes c'est pas du tout
évidemment une volonté de descartes et
d'écarter les femmes la commande était
d'abord la question de la diversité des
provenances nationale des des entrants
sur cette piste et puis d'autre part
c'est vrai qu'on a une difficulté parce
que par exemple vous avez 70 militaires
qui sont honorés dans cette liste parce
qu'ils ont des rendu des services
éminents à la patrie et à la nation à la
république pour dire les choses
clairement aidé à lancer les militaires
évidemment vous n'avez aucune femme
si vous étudiez par exemple la
composition genre est entre guillemets
des des romanciers les gens qui ont
écrit des livres qui sont restés
importants qui ont contribué notablement
au rayonnement culturel de la france
vous avez très peu de femmes dans
l'histoire c'est malheureusement la
réalité
alors on en a mis un certain nombre mais
vous avez raison il
manque c'est un travail à poursuivre et
la liste des 2700 monde qui reste hélas
aussi vous restez avec nous un nicolas
bancel vous réagissez à ce qui va être
dit en plateau nicolas tenzer depuis que
paru cette liste elle fait face à une
avalanche de critiques
j'ai épargné monsieur d'anselme il y en
a d'autres médias réunionnais qui
affirme que lille est la grande oubliée
de cette liste il ad'autres étonné moi
je moi j'ai regardé cette liste de
manière très attentive et je considère
que l'est vraiment telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui elle peut être complétée
bien sûr mais elle est vraiment parfaite
elle est vraiment pas refaire je ne
comprends absolument pas les critiques
que du genre de celle de monsieur
retailleau je veux dire la france elle
est faite de gens qui pour l'essentiel
ont des origines étrangères moi même
d'ailleurs mais quatre grands parents
étaient étrangers ma mère était
étrangère j'ai fait les écoles de la
république et la voilà c'est donc je dis
donc pourquoi des gens je dire des six
mois on voit des gens qu'ils ont des dd
africains ont des asiatiques ça a été
rappelé qu' qui ont combattu qui ont
versé leur sang au nom de la france
on voit des gens qui sont des grands
écrivains des chanteurs des artistes des
hommes de théâtre qui sont venus de
l'étranger parce que l'exil c'est la
richesse de la france et c'est ça qui
fait la force de ce pays c'est d'avoir
des étrangers qui l'ont façonnée et qui
se reconnaissent aujourd'hui français à
part entière parfois beaucoup plus
français que ceux qui se prétendent
aujourd'hui c'est faux patriotes les
français de souche a entre guillemets un
tous ces gens là d'ailleurs qui sont
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux prêts
à vendre la france à des puissances
étrangères
d'abord réagi aux propos de monsieur
retailleau austère qui ne confond les
combats qui est un certain nombre de
gens qu'ils veuillent sous la matrice
d'une idéologie revoir l'histoire de
france et des vis et des statuts c'est
une chose et c'est un débat je pense
qu'on prend l'histoire dans sa globalité
donc le débat existe sur est-ce qu'on
doit célébrer napoléon à l'occasion des
commémorations pas est ce que c'est un
débat très large et on trouvera toujours
au laser de l'histoire quelque chose qui
n'est pas politiquement correct et puis
la deuxième chose c'est quelque part de
suggérer un certain nombre de noms issus
comme on dit de la diversité moi ça me
choque
absolument pas mais il faut quand même
garder moi c'est sa matrice le caractère
universel de notre message
autant une suggestion est bonne et moi
même j'ai regardé la liste qui ne m'a
pas choqué autant attention la politique
des quotas dans les noms parce qu'on a
chacun y va de sa matrice je rajouterais
la mienne et vous allez voir qu'elle
n'est pas sur le genre moi je suis assez
d'accord un par ailleurs parce que
spontanément le comment dire le machisme
et la misogynie institutionnel fait que
on l'a vu sur des prix nobel incertains
sont attribués des prix nobel alors que
c'était des femmes qui avaient trouvé il
faut faire un effort particulier mais
par contre il ya une chose qui dans les
deux assemblées puisqu'ici nous sommes à
public sénat et dont les nombreux évoqué
pose toujours un problème c'est la
diversité sociale et ça je pense que un
effort doit être fait pour ces héros du
quotidien mais pas seulement
si je pense ne se simplement la france
combattante
que ce soient les lycéens du lycée
buffon ou le groupe manouchian la ftp
moy
je crois qu'il faut aussi mettre en
avant
finalement ces héros des classes
populaires d'où qu'ils viennent parce
qu'il y aura un nouveau ton manoukian
est dans la liste d'assas et bien le
loire heureusement mais il me semble que
dans certaines villes et je le dis aussi
l'idéologie nous rattrape dans certaines
villes le groupe manouchian où les
fédérés de la commune pour parler des
étrangers qui ont façonné l'histoire
sont plus présents sur les noms de rue
que dans d'autres nicolas bancel vous
souhaitez réagir
oui juste pour vous entièrement d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être ce qui vient
d'être dit et la liste je le rappelle
pour que les téléspectateurs soient
vraiment au courant de l'intention de
ses fils ce n'est pas de remplacer le
long des rues ans et de proposer à tous
les aigus et maires conseillers généraux
régionaux des possibilités une ouverture
sur le monde sur les petits fleuves qui
ont fait le grand fleuve
quelle histoire quelle histoire de
france et que moi je ne suis
personnellement un petit personne mais
je crois que justement c'est partagé par
le conseil scientifique s'agit pas donc
de le déboulonner les statues ou
d'enlever des noms de rues mais pour les
nouveaux bâtiments les nouveaux édifices
des nouvelles rues et cetera je crois
qu'on a le droit effectivement de
réfléchir peut-être à plus large échelle
et il en va pas d'une mauvaise volonté
des élus genre fiction et peut-être
d'une méconnaissance aussi tout
simplement de la richesse de notre
histoire qui est effectivement irrigué
par l'ensemble c'est de ces petits
ruisseaux qui ont fait sept grands
fleuves qui nous habite
prenons un exemple de quelqu'un qui est
vraiment identifié comme étant français
et qui est dans votre liste d'ailleurs
jacques tati yves jacques tati tchouk
voilà et tout le monde l'identifient un
français mais il c'est quelqu'un qui
vient à une origine étrangère
vous avez des des chanteurs aussi dans
votre liste mais qui sont effectivement
tellement identifié comme étant étant
des français qu'on en a oublié l'origine
et je trouve que c'est ça aussi la force
de ce message nicolas bancel un tout
dernier mot rapidement vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir été instrumentalisé à
des fins politiques par certains et
certaines alors 13 dépend pas du tout
parce que je tiens à dire que le conseil
scientifique a agi avec une liberté
absolument entière on a eu absolument
aucune pression on a choisi en toute
liberté vous avez vu conseil
scientifique est très divers et recoupe
des historiens comme moi comme pascal
ory qui d'ailleurs vêtements
académicien même si des journalistes des
des gens qui s'intéressent à la
diversité et on a eu absolument aucune
pression donc on agit vraiment toute
liberté et ben merci merci beaucoup
nicolas bancel d'avoir participé de
manière ponctuelle comme ça ce match des
idées merci infiniment
troisième thème ce soir messieurs c'est
la troisième conférence social jean
castex se rencontraient les partenaires
sociaux en visio pourparlers prime aux
salariés 10 de la deuxième ligne dans
cette crise à savoir les chauffeurs
routiers les livreurs les caissières les
éboueurs au total 4,6 millions de
personnes voudraient qu'on écoute jean
castex à l'issue de cette réunion
il s'agit de manifester une
reconnaissance aux salariés dont la
présence au travail s'est avérée
indispensable pour assurer la continuité
économique du pays tout au long de la
crise au terme des échanges avec les
partenaires sociaux
le gouvernement a décidé d'autoriser à
nouveau comme ces deux dernières années
le versement en 2021 d'une prime de 1000
euros défiscalisées et exonérées de
cotisations sociales plus communément
connu sous l'appellation de prime macron
françois kalfon est-ce que ça non je
vous vois faire une tête je me dis que
ça ne vous va pas du tout non mais moi
j'ai écouté et nos tonomy du dialogue
social c'est une vieille tradition la
charte d'amiens en france je constate
que l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales de salariés ont refusé la
funeste réforme l'assurance chômage qui
va précariser ce qui au terme de ce
processus
voilà emplois détruits donc la prime
macron 2000 euros pour les salariés dont
je pense que si on fait une conférence
sociale la base c'est qu'on est tous et
une écoute les partenaires sociaux donc
on retire cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage dans le contexte sa part est
d'accord mais ce n'était pas l'objet des
disques bien jour ses collages et
d'assurer qu'il est la prime mais
attendez mais attendez on va chercher la
paille dans l'oeil du voisin alors qu'on
a une poutre en face de ses yeux n'a pas
une de poutres on en a deux puisque
derrière il ya aussi la situation des
jeunes 1
il y à des collectifs d'associations qui
demande
la possibilité même transitoire moi je
serais prêt à ce que ce soit pour le
temps de résilience de la crise pour
deux ans trois ans à ce que le rsa
jeunes puissent être instituée enfin
est-ce qu'il ya besoin d'aller faire des
colloques sous les lambris dorés de la
république pour voir que notre jeunesse
est en situation de graves difficultés
tant sur le plan matériel que
psychologique voilà deux urgences
sociales qui font le consensus d'un côté
des associations et de l'autre des
partenaires sociaux et on va vous nous
invitez nous inventer une prime qui a
pour les salariés de la deuxième ligne
sa pêche l'urgence sociale dans le très
bien et très bien qui fleure bon
finalement le ral l'oral de rattrapage
électorale alors que les revendications
sont tout à fait claires et ça concerne
des centaines de milliers de personnes
sur le plan de cette funeste réforme de
l'assurance-chômage chocolatées j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya eu un certain nombre
de mesures qui ont été actés qui sont
trop sensuelle ça c'était assez évident
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut aussi
que les entreprises prennent leur part
de responsabilité en tout cas celles qui
le peuvent
prenons tout ne peuvent-elles pas
effectivement en versant cette prime
parce que là aussi il faut être sûr
aussi que derrière évidemment les
salariés concernés reçoivent cette prime
parce que l'incitation de ce point de
vue l'homme ne suffit pas et je crois
que là il faut aussi être clairs et
probablement être un peu plus
contraignant
encore une fois pas pour toutes les
entreprises mais celles qui ont pu
dégager pendant la crise notamment le
grand commerce l'agroalimentaire etc
un certain nombre de profits tout à fait
raisonnable deuxièmement il ya
effectivement lucia calvo l'a rappelé il
ya 2 2 où il peine trois grands sujets a
effectivement cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage à vrai dire on n'en
comprend pas très bien les fondements
dans la période actuelle je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui pouvait
certainement attendre qu'ils devaient
attendre je dis pas qu'il faut pas
réformer non je pense que même sur le
fond il ya sortons certainement un
certain nombre de mesures à prendre
c'est certainement pas le moment compte
tenu de la situation de précarité
terrible d'ailleurs non aux mesures pas
encore exactement tous les contours 1
mais on va voir ce qui va se passer dans
six mois dans un an dans deux ans on
peut craindre quand même une
détérioration extraordinairement
sérieuses pour les catégories les plus
vulnérables sur le fond de landau le
monde d'après
voilà mais voilà c'est ça va lier sa
deuxième mariage on repart en parler ce
soir il ya la question effectivement de
la réforme des retraites bon qui a été
mal engagée
je pense qu'elle ne sera pas parce que
je pense que dans le contexte
aujourd'hui elle est complètement
illisibles est impensable
déjà elle était sans doute avant la
crise de lakovic 19 et troisièmement
effectivement il ya la situation des
jeunes et là il ya plusieurs choses je
crois qu'il ya effectivement la
précarité matérielle psychologique d'un
certain nombre de jeunes et je pense
qu'on a beaucoup tardé beaucoup trop
tardé à en prendre la mesure
et aujourd'hui encore je pense que tous
les témoignages affluent je veux dire
c'est un véritable désastre désastre
tomber et deuxièmement il ya là de
l'étape d'après c'est à dire pour les
jeunes
comment vont-ils s'insérer sur le marché
de l'emploi par les stages par le
premier emploi dans l'écho dans le
contexte aujourd'hui et je veux le
gouvernement n'en fait pas assez dit là
je pense qu'il va effectivement il ya
probablement un certain ya des mesures
d'urgence il ya des mesures d'urgence et
il ya ensuite un certain nombre de
mesures vraiment de transition avant la
visage et pour les deux prochaines
années ou trois prochaines années pour
que les jeunes effectivement puissent
accéder dans les meilleures conditions
possibles au marché de l'emploi
et là je pense que c'est ce sujet-là
prioritairement qui doit être mis sur la
table alors je suis tout à fait d'accord
pourquoi et maintiennent t-il cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage
c'est pour des raisons politiques c'est
elle qui à un moment donné pour en
concurrence avec la droite et le courant
dit réformateur faut toujours plus de
réformes ayant acté la fin de la réforme
des retraites il faut maintenir une
réforme au parfum un peu libérale et qui
en sont les dindons de la farce pas ceux
qui sont les plus fragilisés
c'est à dire les demandeurs d'emploi
ensuite s'il y avait eu et moi j'ai dit
un certain nombre de pistes comme le rsa
jeunes mais c'est pas le seul s'il y
avait eu un sommet social qui faisait
sens pour la société
bien au delà des organisations
syndicales c'est de ce sommet social
pour la jeunesse un dans lequel toutes
les parties prenantes y compris les
collectivités locales auraient été
invités à y participer
moi je pense que dans une période comme
ça il faut pas faire preuve de
dogmatisme typiquement vous avez ce
sujet qui apparaît sur la violences
entre jeunes et qui est devant nous
berck les phénomènes de bandes ça
toujours existé mais la montée de la
violence n'est pas sans rapport avec la
situation sociale dans laquelle nous
vivons
et bien c'est le moment d'injecter
massivement des assistants d'éducation
c'est le moment d'être innovant et qu'on
ne me dise pas qu'il n'ya pas d'argent
on peut y revenir et ouvrir pardon mais
laissez ça non mais je cite quand même
deux chiffres 750 milliards d'euros pour
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
1900 milliards aux états unis avec la
fed la banque centrale aurait pu le
faire et un pays comme le seul japon
chiffre son plan de relance à 2000
milliards environ 2 de dollars ou
d'euros
on n'est plus à ça près donc ces lettres
les marges de manoeuvre existent riz sur
les jeunes je précise juste la toute
dernière info quand même si la prime à
l'embauché des jeunes qui est prolongé
jusqu'au 31 mai voilà je sais que ça ne
vous dira pas mais celle annonces du
jour une petite image pour terminer si
vous le voulez bien la visite de quatre
français au vatican ce lundi les
militants écologistes cyril dion
l'entrepreneuse eva sadoul le fondateur
du mouvement coexister samuel grychowski
qui ont rencontré le pape est un
collaborateur de l'eurodéputé pierre
larrouturou qui s'est fait excuser qui
devait venir mais qu'ils étaient
positifs au co vide de quoi ont-ils
parlé de taxation sur les transactions
financières pour accélérer la transition
écologique
le souverain pontife qui a appelé la
jeunesse à réveiller les gouvernements
sur les questions environnementales et
plus surprenant selon nos confrères de
l'ops le pape s'est inquiété du risque
de voir le rassemblement national au
pouvoir en france
je pense que c'est tout à fait normal
parce que tout simplement le message du
rassemblement rasd nationale est
totalement opposée aux enseignements
fondamentaux de l'église catholique
je ne suis pas catholique moi même peu
importe d'ailleurs mais il faut bien
voir que si on regarde ce que propose le
rassemblement national et les évangiles
c'est complètement je dirais l'antinomie
absolue l'antinomie absolue donc le
rassemblement national n'a rien n'à
parti chrétien et je crois que si
l'embarras alors si le pape est
intervenu aussi je crois sur le
rassemblement national
c'est pour aussi indiqué quelque chose
je pense qu'il l'a dit très spontanément
c'est que le rassemblement national
n'est pas un parti comme un autre
le rassemblement national ne fait pas
partie du jeu politique normal dans une
démocratie et je crois que c'est ce
message là très fort du souverain
pontife
aujourd'hui il faut véritablement
entendre c'est un coup de l'arbre alors
bien sûr après sur l'engagement
environnemental du pape il est connu
depuis longtemps
lui même d'ailleurs lorsqu'il était
avant d'être pape ait eu lorsqu'il était
archevêque cardinal etc a fait beaucoup
pour la jeunesse évidemment de simple et
je concept ce rendez-vous prouve qu'ils
avaient il y avait un véritable intérêt
elle c'est quelqu'un d'ouvert voilà et
je pense qu'il a dit des choses très
fortes
à cette occasion et c'est malin de la
part de ces quatre français de passer
par le pas pour faire passer ses
messages comme pour faire pression sur
des gouvernement qui serait sourd à ces
sur les sujets environnementaux voit
bien qu'il ya pâtissier de frontières
c'est un sujet mondial
or le pape est que dans une religion
structuré puisque c'est de la religion
de le monothéisme qui a une autorité
suprême comme médiation chez les vivants
qui est quel pape s'est plutôt bien que
le faire sur la question du
rassemblement national
quand on va à saint pierre de rome
michel et quand j'étais gamin puis je
suis retourné récemment
et quand même une sculpture sur la place
saint-pierre c'est quand même voulu par
le pape françois duquel je suis un peu
fan je tiens à dire et qui est un bateau
avec des migrants donc l'engagement
sacerdotale personnel politique de ce
jésuite argentin il est tout à fait
clair d'ailleurs au prix moi je ne fais
pas partie des communautés catholiques
au prix parfois de frottement sur ses
engagements qui ne plaisent pas à tous
les catholiques dans le monde et en
france mais qui me sont plutôt
sympathiques et le fait qu'ils soient
sensibles à la question environnementale
vous le saviez vous je sais qu'il est
sensible à tous moi je n'ai pas à juger
le pape qui a qui ont posé des questions
sur l'homosexualité qui disait et je
dirais avec lui qui suis-je pour juger
donc qui suis-je pour juger les
engagements du pape
je ne juge pas maison
ma sympathie voilà c'est un discours qui
peut avoir de l'influencé sur les états
notamment sur la question
environnementale nicolas tenzer il est
très influent je pense qu'il a ce pape
en particulier à une aura véritable
auprès de l'ensemble des progressistes
partout dans le monde en france en
europe dans le monde et je pense que
c'est un pape à ses ex de la hiérarchie
catholique
bien sûr évidemment des catholiques
d'extrême droite ou de ceux qui se
disent catholiques qui sont à l'extrême
droite plus exactement ça c'est tout à
fait évident mais je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose de très fort effectivement
et sur l'environnement ce n'est pas du
tout la première fois qu'il dit qu'il ya
vraiment un risque pour la planète qu'on
risque de se détruire
et je crois qu'il y a un lien quand même
théologique parce que quand même le pape
françois est aussi théologie loin
peut-être moins que que benoit 16 ne
l'était mais quand même
et il ya aussi un enseignement il faut
préserver la planète il faut la garder
alors il n'est pas du tout dans
l'extrémisme le pape n'est pas du tout
une sorte d'extrémisme verre ultra et
c'est pas du tout mais il envoie des
message très fort et je pense que là
aussi celui sur le rassemblement
national est très clair je pense qu on
soit faut quand même réfléchir assez
sérieusement à cette parole du souverain
pontife et on s'arrêtera là merci merci
tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
match des idées c'est donc la fin de
cette émission exceptionnellement se
retrouvera demain à 18h30 et non à 18
heures et puis je vous retrouverez aussi
à 22h30 dans un instant auditions
publiques l'invité ce soir olivier faur
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
et puis demain matin comme tous les
jours dès 7h30 vous retrouvez bonjour
chez vous oriane mancini recevra
notamment laurent berger secrétaire
général de la cfdt je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur public sénat